[Music]
i give salam to my people in bangladesh
salam to the people of marrakesh
alhamdulillah
brothers and sisters i received a call
the other day from my brother
and he told me about a man that he came
across
in oxford street and this is where we
are right now and he mentioned that this
man
he was on the road and he had two books
with him
and subhanallah he would look at one
book and then look at the other
and he would look at one book and he
would look at the other
we are going to go and meet him right
now insha'allah and show you
what this man was doing come with us
insha'allah
and see the special action that he was
doing
we headed off to find this brother and
he wasn't at the spot
so then we headed off to prayhassar and
made dua
to allah that we find him and the next
thing you know
this happened
[Music]
okay
is there a cup from the evil of the
darkening night as it comes with this
darkness of the moon as it sets above
the way
why men shall enough but satan is full
of god
and from the evil of those who crack his
witchcraft when they're glowing the
knots
ramen
that's how i read all the time every
time you do it like that
every time and then i read the whole
version out of it then i read it all
again in english
and then i'll go over it again and again
how long does it take you to learn
asura for example how long does it have
to learn a surah an hour
in an hour yeah a small one i've been
learning an hour
of a banking hour no problem no problem
it's good to see you you went past
trying to find you
you weren't here and then i went past
her i came back and here you
are you tell me um
what you're doing what are these two
books yeah one's quran in arabic
one's quran in english and
transliteration okay so
i'll just learn to read the arabic
through here okay so that's how i've
learned to read from surah um
assad to the end of the quran in arabic
through translators
of the
yourself yeah out here just looking at
them just looking at just looking at it
okay
so then i matched certain words up so
now i know that that this
verse will start looking
so another way and then so you're
practicing your reading right yeah
and you self-taught yourself you you
help yourself i get a bit of help here
and there with certain words and the
pronunciation is way off the mark
but um can you read something so we can
hear you
waiting
and i think it's very very inspirational
to see somebody
uh just saw the people understand
when i met you now you're somebody who
is very content
and happy uh and proud to be um
in the situation that you're in now you
don't require anybody
rather you don't want anybody to help
you in any shape or form right
yeah you just want to sit here and do
your quran like someone comes and puts a
sandwich or a drinker or
i'm not interested in what's going on
behind me what people are doing what
they're buying what they're not buying
what they're getting up to i don't care
i just really i wanted to give you a
glad tiding
that the smart muslim
the smart muslim is the one who comes
with the best of speech and the best of
action
and you are coming with the best of
speech
and this is the best of action for the
person to sit down and just busy
themselves with the book of allah azza
did not do
anything else this is the best thing a
person could do so no wonder why you're
so content and your heart is full of
contentment and satisfaction it's
because you have this book i'm on my own
so when i went
to talk to me and i told you something
else
the people of the past they used to say
i don't know if you know this quote or
not
they used to say that if you want to
speak to allah
you want to speak to allah they would
say
if you want allah to speak with you so
you knew that right
what is your favorite the quran i want
to read
[Music]
it
[Music]
[Music]
a
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
a
and
[Music]
me
he mentions that the people of the quran
are the people of allah
so amongst all of mankind amongst all of
humanity
those who are closest to allah nearest
to allah
the more special to allah who busy
themselves
and a person may look at their
circumstances and
look at their life and find that maybe
they're struggling
uh maybe you're not allowed
like a king you're living like a king
here bro
you've got life allah bless you i think
i think i think one thing that we
learned from you allah is the quran
has really impacted you that's all i got
and all i need
what do you got all you need i don't
need nothing else you know what we read
allah
i'm not doing this for nothing but end
of the day
they approached me i didn't approach no
one but nothing before i just sit here
and i just
read and i read and i read and read and
read and read and every time every day
i'll keep on reading
and i'll keep on reading even when i get
my house i still come here and still sit
here and read
[Music]
accommodation in this world and a
present accommodation in the heart of
life
anything you need insha'allah
thank you so much
alhamdulillah what a beautiful beautiful
beautiful encounter that was
our beloved brother here clearly he
is a person who is very inspirational
doesn't possess
a lot possesses very little but he is
content
the shoulders are respected brothers and
sisters
do not dismiss anybody and do not think
that because somebody is
higher than you in society that they are
higher than you in the sights of allah
this person is lower than a lot of
people in society but he is higher than
so
many others in the sight of allah
he has just told us that if we bring him
something
he will get upset with us he does not
want anything and he is saying that i
have allah
why do i need anything this is how you
and i should be and it reminded me from
the verse of the book of allah
[Music]
that through the virtue of allah and the
mercy of allah you should rejoice and be
happy
the quran is better than everything you
are gathering he is not gathering
anything
and he is happy with that this is what
the verse is telling us
from the people of the quran those who
hold the quran close to their hearts
despite
any scenario and situation that they are
in subhanallah protect him and preserve
him
allow to be inspired by this encounter
you